[موسيقى]
سلام عليكم انا اسمي انس عندي 12 سنه في
الصف السابع ا مين عارف توماس
ايدسون اكيد اغلبكم
عارفينه بس مش كلكم عارفين ان هو مسجل
اكثر من 250 براءه اختراع
توماسون اختار عليه
اللمبه وكل ده بس خطوه واحده بس اخدها
مكان صغير في المدرسه لما المدرس بتاعه
قال عليه ان هو
فاشل تخيلوا معايا ان حد يقوللك يا فاشل
هتحس بايه هتخطب تحزن هتحس بالياس توماسون
ق لا
لا لا لا مش هستس
فعلا ماسلمش وعمل لنا الاختراعات الم
موجوده دلوقتي ومها
اللمبه وكلنا برضو لازم
منستسلمش ونعمل زي ما هو
عمل وانا برضو اما كنت صغير كنت عايز
اتعلم الطران فكنت بتفرج على اصحابي
ولقيتهم بيلعبوا بالشطر ف طلبت منهم ان هم
يعلموها ي وفعلا علموها
ي وبابا برض
ساعدني
و اشتغلت على نفسي اكترر وبعد كده دخلت في
مسابقه شطران
و طلعت وفي اول ماتش
خسرت ف ما استسلمت وبرده قلت لا مش هستسلم
و في تاني ماتش ركزت شويه وكسبت وعرفت
اكسب فعلا و بس تث ماتش خسرت تاني قلت مش
مشكله المره الجايه هتسب وحقق افضل ما
عندي وبعد كده ركزت على هدفي وشغلت دماغي
وفعلا نجحت
و طلعت المركز الخامس من اول مسابقه ليا
ومن غير
تدريب وبرضو اما كنت بتعلم الروبيك كنت
شفت ابن عمتي كان بيلعب بيه فعجبني وطلبت
منه ان هو يعلمني برده
علمني وبرده بعد كده شفت فيديوهات كتير
عشان اتعلم
اكتر وكنت اول ما تعلمت كنت بعمله في 10
دقاق الست وجوه و بسس دلوقتي بقيت احله في
دقيقه
سته وده اللي انا عايز كله يعمله ان هو ما
يستسلم ويحقق حلمه مهما كان حلمه كبير او
صغير هتحققه ان شاء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
-